one and a two and a hey fatty boy what's
up everybody welcome back to those hard
[ __ ] feelings baby i am your
host this week kevin james ryan
coming at you from down here at totty's
basement but you guys are the
[ __ ] homies and you know that
not even the homies you're [ __ ]
ten dollar homies twenty dollar homies
fifty dollar home you guys are top tier
homies top brass baby
uh my co-host coming at you in a nice
seafoam uh polo shirt knock off
cotton [ __ ] u.s polo association
what is that what kind of brand we
looking at
because there ain't no little guy on a
horse on it i'll tell you that much
harbor bay that wasn't ready before you
start at the broadcast you smell like
low tide
ladies and gentlemen h moley
cheers everyone
that cackle from behind the camera
coming at you is the one and only t-bone
mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what's up dudes what up t-bone
toby mcmullen their shirt does look like
that foam that gets on top of the surf
when they have to shut it down for e
coli yeah i don't like that it's called
sea foam that's calvin not calvin is
this the color the color it so pull
actual polo ralph lauren lauren ralph
lauren ralph
lipschitz is that his real name i think
so
um i could be wrong on that but
i might be or maybe that's jeff ross's
jeff lipschitz something i'm about to
take a lift [ __ ]
um
i believe it's called seafoam green is
that color
from polo yeah hey meryl streep there's
less mustard stains [ __ ] harbor bay
that's what it is i said you smell like
little tired or something i already made
that joke pretty good whatever my mom
has a bunch of shirts that don't fit my
dad anymore
you're in your dad's clothes yeah like a
fat 8th grader
it's a 4xl i'm down i'm down a size oh
yeah i saw it and i'm ready to tell some
kids to get off my lawn
you better hope it's not contagious
i gotta catch this am i
this is this is like that commercial
where they're like don't be like your
parents yeah real heebie-jee that
commercial dude they'll they're talking
about the parking alone on this place
it's great
everybody loves those oh
they're the best they're all right man
they're all right good piece of business
over there progressive don't flow to
beat it uh i got a little bit of news
what are you regarding uh
the outfit
my outfit no the company okay company
the company uh-oh woke up the other day
yeah
to some charges on our card that were
not authorized listen [ __ ] i took my
[ __ ] niece to lunch you told me i
could i'm not it was less than 100. no
i'm not talking about you at the blue
belt and trust me i know
this guy's all over me
62-87
i don't like that
i don't like that
i want to see it too i want to know
where you're going
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
i had a salad
how was the claims casino fatty holy
[ __ ]
i
called this grace i called and requested
an itemized breakdown like i'm dealing
with jack reacher over here this is
[ __ ] terrible call and asking to talk
to the server look buddy he wasn't
authorized to take you 30 i'm gonna i'm
gonna need eight bucks back
i did leave about 30 35
i used to work there that's not what i'm
talking about
um toby
a bunch of skateboards and trucks
knee pads
um
did you ever hear a kid call them nebo
pads back in the day
there's a real suspect kid in my
cul-de-sac deck you got your elbow pads
and your knee bow pads no that's what's
all real that's real [ __ ] dirt
factory [ __ ]
um
no i no not those charges those are fine
i told you of course that's you you know
it's your company card you're allowed to
use it for company you were
talking we're hiring your niece as an
intern or something i was talking shop
winner yeah okay jesus christ ixnay on
the axes tay
that's going to come back and [ __ ]
bring this whole this whole system dave
becky was also there too
[Laughter]
and the guy from lionsgate stay in
something
um
stan lionsgate
johnny lionsgate
um
what what's going on sorry i'm in the
middle so my [ __ ]
my wife is
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] just give me one second she's
at the bank it's a thing she's jammed up
she needs a marriage certificate amero
what the [ __ ] what kind of bank ass for
a marriage certificate
oh jesus she had to recently change her
name all these you got to prove that why
she changed she's changing her name she
already has really she's nadine kippy
[Laughter]
nadine bull little dick guy
[Laughter]
it's a
hyphenate whatever i'm back okay what's
going on typical broad [ __ ] thing
she's like never mind i found it right
as i set it up abroad who's in our
account exactly so i i log in is it
russia i log into our
i'm
sorry i log into our chase banking uh
institution all right we're talking
about the blue card not amex yeah okay
and i see cause i was home hold on no
yeah yeah no no trust me i got i got a
homing device on you you're [ __ ] dude
you're like sonar stuffed an air tag
[Laughter]
have you checked behind your ears
there's a tag number zx14
um
i got it all right
this is sorry this happened so long ago
because we've been we've been moving and
shaking with mr with sir louis ck you
know
um so we're a little uh you've been
absconding with some funds no i wish i
tried to manage it sounds like [ __ ]
robbing you idiots blind if i didn't
have a soul um if i didn't have a soul
i would if i
yeah if i didn't have one i would be
robbing you blind so you do have a soul
yeah
okay what's going on um
so i get an email uh-huh
from ubereats
twitch because you don't all right so
for the listener foley doesn't it fully
has a credit card a company credit card
yeah proper credit yeah i have the bank
card right right
the real juice um the real mother's milk
i could do more damage with the amex if
i want it though
uh
no i can always claim that is stolen and
i'll replace the funds real quick get me
hemmed up in bogota um let's see sorry
um so i get an email okay
from ubereats
do i have it attached to my account
no okay cause i was i just checked and
there's a but i was pretty sure this
wasn't that card okay oh man you're both
[ __ ] suspect now i don't know who to
trust i thought maybe we had ordered out
on the road or something and it got put
into my [ __ ] no no no no no so hold on i
forgot how good this i forgot the the
layers of this i apologize let me just
get my uh my my
stuff bearing straight yeah get your
story straight is what it [ __ ] sounds
like
i'm hooking you up to a [ __ ]
polygraph this is egregious
i just [ __ ] got a new lease god damn
it i feel like sal and the boys are in
the other room and they're in here
somebody get murph
i was talking to mr volcano earlier
today shout out to him what the [ __ ]
where is this man
this is [ __ ] killing me hey you're
bozoing this up i know what i i'm sorry
you know it's i want to have my ducks
roll because you're going to ask 5 000
[ __ ] questions and i want to have all
you get your lies straight
that's what you want what'd you get at
uber
i didn't get anything yeah so i wake up
where the [ __ ] is it tuesday
i wake up at an uber eats
[Laughter]
sorry bear with me i woke up in a bag
full of popcorn shrimp i didn't know
what was going on
we're vamping folks
jesus sorry [ __ ] i don't know why it's
not searching it doesn't come up
because this whole story's a [ __ ]
that's right you're [ __ ] lying
see i would have had fake emails [ __ ]
fake references the whole nine yards
hard to keep the placement under the
bright lights hey baldy
take you downtown find out what you
[ __ ] know sick the dog on you yours
i'll tell you who looks great right now
who hank
this guy i mean you lie without breaking
a sweat buddy i'm lying right now
i'm not even wearing a seafoam shirt
that's how good i am
it looks quite soft thank you all right
so what's the date
we're broadcasting i'm trying man
tell toby to [ __ ] cut it or not what
are we doing just hold on just [ __ ]
give me a second i'm sorry
i'm okay everybody's okay the homies
except the people who stole from us
which would be
uh or whatever so i all right
you're killing me here because you're
breaking my stones but i gotta find it
okay so we get
i haven't found it i get i i get an
email from ubereats your your your
chipotle order
me no just listen to the [ __ ] email
if i could read the email if you weren't
[ __ ] breaking my back gotta
understand i'm back backtracking the
last 30 days to see if i did anything
wrong it's not you you're in the clear
really i'll go i'll go over the amex
charges shortly um
i get an email
hey your order has been delivered we're
gonna need to see that
[Music]
hey unfortunately i'll get [ __ ] i'll
get liz cheney in here she'll get to the
bottom of it
yeah just wait uh honestly just just
hold it so okay so i have it
we're gonna jump cut to the magic
of cinema
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
where the [ __ ] is it man
i forgot how deep this went
[Laughter]
see now we gotta put that back in hell
luke mark it down
all right you find it
i get an email the problem was it wasn't
okay hold on and we're back you got to
jump back in yeah you ready
and we're back kibby just said that he
has nine different emails
that's what that put out there on record
i do well i have the are you garbage i
have anything happens to me in toby i
have three i have four that was like me
and foley just got yelled at by the
teacher and they were like the next
person to laugh gets fired we're trying
to be respectful and quiet and just
giggling yeah for the for the homie out
there we've been sitting here for about
a half an hour this bozo [ __ ] digs up
his lies
[ __ ] emails laptops
what the [ __ ] so i get an email
so
this came in we thursday we were in the
studio last literally but me and you
ordered chipotle last thursday
right
and i so
i wake up friday and i have an email it
says your this is from chipotle
it's been delivered and i'm like
that's weird i'm like why is it coming
in a day late you know or whatever
so
i'm a
[ __ ] new guy luke's all over me dude
you stink today
it's new guy luke's first full tip for
full-time day he's been blowing me up
like well he's got plenty of work to do
on this episode
jesus christ
[ __ ] spit it out so because your
chipotle order is in uh-huh daniel
and i go
this don't [ __ ] something's up here
so i start looking i'm like maybe it's
foley you know i don't know like you
know that's like my first thought but
then i'm like oh no of course it is it's
not on my what'd he get uh
well i got it all
right i have the man's address he got it
delivered to his house i have the
address oh let's go so it's 61.50 did he
get the extra glock
61.50 what that's queso money
this is ridiculous he got a steak
burrito white rice black beans guacamole
for 320 extra
uh you got one burrito two burrito
barbacoa barbacoa bowl
uh let's go to his house
he tipped three bucks on it i gotta give
him that a piece of [ __ ] it was a 61
order but use dark used our debit card
how do you get the i don't know all at
chipotle.com but it somehow
got he must have hacked
my
i'm thinking of this now
why did i get the email do you think
he's the hacker
somebody hacked my chipotle account i
guess that has our debit card saved in
it maybe wow [ __ ] you can't because why
i got the email if he just had my if he
just had the credit card information he
wouldn't email me and tell me he's doing
it what a bizarre way to use that elite
set of skills
that's what i'm saying hackers get
hungry though you gotta give them that
maybe it's just he constantly does that
but but with the address
i don't know the back door to these fast
casual servers are wide open it's where
woburn massachusetts [ __ ] those
dirty dirty we're calling the fbi
gas up the kia grab a cobar we're going
on a road no [ __ ]
give it a give that address a goo i have
it
i have dude i have the street number i
have does it say one two three
mockingbird does it say he lives there
what do you mean
no does it say like no if you google it
if you google the number the address
uh-huh does it come up daniel [ __ ]
alicoa whatever oh we're gonna do a
little catfish here yeah we should
i was thinking if we just go to his
house but
that's just me did he put a phone number
to call on the order oh let me check oh
my god please for the love of god
hey you [ __ ] we can't call him we'll
[ __ ] get into our phones
yeah that way you then we're all [ __ ]
yeah
that's not that doesn't work yes it does
i did it to my mom they didn't she lied
to you she did other stuff
hey you can't just
answer a phone call and they hack into
your [ __ ] we're gonna get the patty oh
wait a second what so this is the
address to the chipotle yeah
your delivery oh no no i'm sorry yeah i
have his i do have his
i do have his we got a case cooking here
gang uh-huh this is i forget this is why
i wanted to give me the time this is
real juicy all right i told you it was
just all right all right
all right
so obviously i'm not gonna say the
address why not
i don't know what if it's not him and we
blow him up and they [ __ ] and alex
tenello goes
hey talk to you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
put it away
oh
uh yes let's see all right fine
um
that's what you do
man i don't trust any of these things
damn it's an expensive house
you're stealing it's [ __ ] 900
thousand dollar house and you're
stealing my goddamn chipotle money [ __ ]
how do you think you pay for the house
he's probably a kid
it's probably a fake name his parents it
is i think currently for sale maybe so
maybe he just got it delivered he's out
front like it's not his real dr i don't
know how he's paying for any [ __ ]
good for a [ __ ] offer for a burrito
bowl i know are you kidding me that's
crazy that's got a switch car what a
[ __ ] loser he's doing the drop
he's in a parking garage somewhere
sweeping up hairs at the barbershop i
just switched cars three times hey man
you could have reached out to me to bite
your lunch he's got he's got the
he's got the nun mask on and a [ __ ]
ak
he's covered
[Laughter]
all right so you got this punk's address
so i got the address
did you hold on did you are there any
other charges so that's another thing so
i caught so i have to be a murder charge
i'll tell you that
what do you get what do you get for
breakfast this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i
pull up uh
so i'm like all right you know uh so if
right away i'm like oh i'm [ __ ] start
scanning i don't know who the [ __ ] spent
this is what's this charge what's this
there's a couple lines i call up [ __ ]
chase i start and i'm like you listen
someone's using my card freeze the card
they freeze the card chase freezes the
card and go we'll send out a new one i
go i can't go to a chase and get one
printed i live right next door they go
no i go well when's it going to be here
he goes 10 business days i'm like the
[ __ ] how am i supposed to pay for it i'm
like how am i supposed to run a business
without a credit card he goes if you
need any money just go to the bank i'm
not going to the bank every 15 times a
day he's like you live right next to him
sorry i can see where you're calling
from can you at least get me some
chipotle
his order was pretty good
the daniel dirtball meal at chipotle
like jack arlo what did he get there was
two meats on there no there was multiple
uh where was it
uh let's see what did he get he got a
steak burrito hold on a steak burrito
okay 16 beans right yeah yeah
16 bucks for the steak beezy uh-huh
that's guac and all that then he got the
pollo asado burrito
uh-huh that was 1480. this is a whole
crew he ain't eating all this food
you think one guy's big enough to pull
this job off no way
there's a whole system of probably some
[ __ ] sleeper selling on this thing oh
feds are probably in on it
they've been [ __ ] playing in this
whole month oh no this whole thing's
been a setup holy [ __ ]
you one guy's gonna rip me off okay i'm
the prince of [ __ ] park avenue baby
king of the [ __ ] board see
we're on people's radar now i don't i'm
going off the grid you think some
[ __ ] dirt bag and [ __ ] woe burn
mess is gonna [ __ ] rip me off all
right so we got two burritos
we got it by the woburn bandit
it's gonna have been [ __ ] wapo
what is it wampo
uh so we got two burritos
and a barbacoa bowl they probably split
that
to pay off the cops
a little bit of walking around me you
know and that was delivered to that
address
delivered to an address that i have
that we i mean we have the
address see if we can get a number on
that a phone number
all right nobody's got landlines anymore
and they usually guard them online you
have to pay you have to pay a service to
get the number yeah hmm
i mean what the [ __ ] man what a piece of
[ __ ]
property records now we're talking yikes
you wanna hack i can hack too
no we can't
www.hacker.com
as soon as i remember my password you're
[ __ ]
dead as soon as i find my correct email
address user all done
holy [ __ ]
all right so what are the charges i do
have a name or 140
okay
that's not it
that's my social security number
299.
you [ __ ] stink today
i'll tell you that this guy's all
[ __ ] all thumbs
all forehead
all right 36 records found for someone
who lives at this
address yeah age 23
that's probably
that's prime hacker age yeah that's
hacking
go play fortnite [ __ ] nerd
probably listen is it a show
you think
if they listen to the show i'd allow it
at that point
no no
[Laughter]
start freaking out
don't rob me beach
um
so i assume they hacked my chipotle
that's it
chipotle's got to hear about this their
firewalls uh compromised
what's that all about
so was that was there other charges
i just searched uh if there's been a
leak at chipotle it's just people
complaining about shitty burritos
my bag's leaking it's the goddamn
guacamole you didn't put the lid on
correctly
you didn't put a lid on my [ __ ] diet
i thought they forgot something daniel
yeah i hope they gave you a regular coke
son of a dick yeah i hope they screwed
you on the [ __ ] cutlery didn't give
you silverware yeah [ __ ]
eating with a pig we'll try to eat that
with a chip
that aliko is heavy
whatever it's called
barbacoa
i'm paul alakowa
and i'm a hacker
what the [ __ ]
okay you stink
so
i start rolling through the charge i'm
like this this and i realize they all
are valid charges just all like our uber
eats and uber
you know the [ __ ] we're down here at the
good time cafe and all this stuff
i didn't [ __ ] have this i didn't have
i didn't get coffee right next to the
studio um so it was just one charge one
charge for 61.50
yeah they probably roll i mean they
probably just have thousands of those
cards they use it try keep trying to use
it i assume but like it's pretty nuts
that we have
he's brazen you wanna hear something
nuts too okay the name
yeah is daniel ryan
the plot
it's an inside job i assume this is my
thought
they got i was maybe they hacked in
i don't even know if i have a chipotle
account i assume i do
did you at any point
order food for your brother and people
and maybe it was saving them on his
phone why why would he be in [ __ ]
outside boston that's what we'd like to
know
[Laughter]
daniel
[Laughter]
yeah
i've been from boston this whole time
[Laughter]
flocking i tell you what you sold the
philly accent really good
okay
okay
so
somebody wants to play hardball
all right
so i assume it was some sort of like
yakuza deal no like you know when they
when these things get hacked or
compromised you don't get all of the
information right like it like some of
it comes like you get the credit card
number and not the name or you get a
portion of the name and whatever
whatever they could have been
they could have been like oh it needs i
got to put my name kevin ryan in to for
you know and they just guessed daniel or
found out my brother's daniel or
something i don't know
or you're in on it
i'm in on it there's only three options
yeah they were barbacoa steak burrito
and polio
what's your usual order what
yeah it's not barbico i don't touch the
stuff i swear
it's all over you
um
so what do we got let's let's let's be
serious here so we got an address i got
it where it was delivered to
yes you don't have a phone you don't
have his phone number let me see
um order details it's just that payment
method kippy's credit card
that's a fat loser's card um
yeah that's it there's no other there's
no number no contact number where's this
guy live barbacoa massachusetts
[Laughter]
your order is in daniel what is it what
is it it was 8 36 p.m
on 6 24. a lot of carbs that late at
night that is pretty late
probably cup big boys were playing with
here
probably a couple of heavy bikes
[Laughter]
you know what dan enjoy the burritos
what do you know i need to see what that
was all just for him he's like the liver
king [ __ ] [ __ ] calorie you've
really been pushing liver king
every every casual conversation you
somehow get back to that guy too
what was the what massachusetts whitman
uh
woe burn mass w.o burn
[Music]
wow see if there is a daniel ryan in
woburn massachusetts
owner carpenter daniel ryan carpentry
whoa whoa
that is a that is a common irish dirtbag
name i got 158 dan ryan's it will burn
yeah
they're probably all in on it
yeah um
but chase did reverse the charge took a
couple of days i lost interest on that
[ __ ] screw me every way
every way they can they're [ __ ] send
some extra napkins or something do you
let's go to the street view of this
let's see this daniel j ryan woburn
massachusetts 105 westgate drive
apartment 3 87 years old this is our guy
it's probably his grandson or something
hello
it's like whitey bulger all over again
i'm on the street i got the street right
here you said it's an apartment
no that was a different address
what's that address i think it showed me
the wrong house or something i don't
want i don't know who to believe in this
i don't know what's going on
i think this is it right here
[ __ ] dirtbags should go [ __ ]
firebomb the place oh that's nice wait
but so it's a house not an apartment
i don't know i never said it was an
apartment did i i thought you did you
said apartment three
i said that yeah i didn't say that but i
was just trying to hide the lead of him
being 87.
our other our other strongest lead is
101 years old oh man i probably got
nothing to live for at that point so
yeah turn to a life of crime
those old people steal
you know how they do some people do
retire start goading
all right so
maybe i'll rob a bald fat kid from
pennsylvania
order a couple burritos that'll fix them
you are you woody from toy story i was
doing brooks i thought that it's
actually pretty accurate i'll give it to
you
um
all right let's see what else what else
can we find out about this
7e i'm not really getting there's
nothing listed on that i don't even
think this place i don't think this is a
house should we dust the email for
fingerprints
is guacamole all over it
not that on it
piece of [ __ ]
they got us
i don't think there technically is a 146
block of this street though
he probably waited on the corner i see a
144 a 148
oh man this goes deeper than i thought
this is a mysterious episode
so
we got got the good people over there
chase took care of it shout out to him
you know which chipotle saying you talk
to them
now kind of just once they gave us our
60 bucks back it kind of just folded we
could call it chipotle
and there's any suspicious characters
hanging out around there you want to
call yeah any guys with masks and sacks
with money signs on them
anybody with an old-timey gun by any
chance
gonna be going yeah a lot
give me the burrito you see what's the
curlicue mustache situation
um
i'm gonna tie this bra to the train
tracks get a burrito bowl i sh
that's enough toby
chipotle train tracks really well
yeah i mean i think
you know how many people you think he's
doing us two though probably a lot
probably every [ __ ] meal is floating
a taxpayer's dime
piece of [ __ ]
but where how the [ __ ] did they get my
email address well you're not [ __ ]
the pentagon i know but
why not if you got why not use someone
else's email address
so they have my card and my email
address that's what i'm saying doesn't
make sense i don't think i have a
[ __ ] chipotle oh maybe i'd do let's
see if i can sign in
chipotle he probably changed your
password
that's the first move they do
but it was to an obscure
account obscure uh
an obscure account email account
and i'm in
wait i mean i do
it says hey daniel let's go what the
[ __ ] let's go
let's go
what do i do from here i need to see let
me go to go to account i'll take the
chips
i need to see a menu quick
go to go to get a couple of tacos
holy [ __ ] it says hey daniel
he's hacked into your chipotle account
he is you i got 489 points and
technically he owns half of the podcast
daniel for that reason you're out
you got to do a podcast with daniel god
damn it
um
whoa i feel like i'm in someone else's
house right now go to he's in your house
[ __ ] [ __ ] make a move
everybody hit the ground
what do you got nobody move what do you
got nothing i have 489 points i can
redeem for a fountain drink or a side of
gold
who do you want you want the drinker to
glock
i know i'm gonna steal a watercolor what
do you know about the perp what are you
doing i'm gonna steal a water cup
all right he's probably doing that if we
didn't order a drink how are you gonna
eat all that all that [ __ ] mexican
i'm gonna get something let me use the
bathroom first i know this kid's ammo
pick up from and it's 112 commerce way
no a pickup
yeah that's that that's the closest
store is 112 commerce so that's where he
let's map out the store to the to the
address triangulate them yeah let's
let's go back to the scene of the crew
get my whiteboard
and my red yarn this is about to get
wacky and my cheeseboard
wait a minute did the kid have it
delivered or did the kid get delivered
delivered all right but i want to walk
in the shoes you know what i mean it
could be right around the corner or
something this could be an inside job
who even knows
that would make sense
they're just making dummy orders sending
them a [ __ ] vacant place and
everybody's laughing on my dime if you
work at chipotle
who knows people are sick how high does
this go yeah oh [ __ ] pelosi is probably
in on it
um
all right
crazy i don't i mean my i don't want to
suggest this but it could be my dad
he maybe moved to boston and stole my
identity
no why would he do that
he wouldn't be able to do he doesn't
have a hack he doesn't he doesn't even
have cable i think he's got a flip phone
if you go under account
what is it 10 minute drive from where
from the chipotle it was a 10-minute
drive to drop off daniel's food
okay so it's within a 10-minute vicinity
this is if you take commerce way to why
or whatever well how are you gonna get
there
whoa
whoa
whoa
or h fully boulevard
[Applause]
do you make a left on mcmullen way he's
in a band called the boneheads what the
[ __ ]
okay all right i pushed it yeah you did
so did toby with the tracks line i was
vamping
what is vamping by the way i'm feeling
the oh you know like a band vamps like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're filling
the dead air yeah plenty of that in this
one folks
like johnny computers hey it paid off
this is a [ __ ] we're hot on the trail
right here oh i feel like neve from
[ __ ] catfish
[Laughter]
if you go under account
it'll it should have like address saved
and perhaps
contact information
in a photo
my bag is empty hey daniel i click on
the account
view points history extras my rewards my
profile edit profile i'm looking man
payment methods
you
yeah he's got my [ __ ] credit card
it's safe had it it's canceled now oh it
is canceled hope you're starving
that's going to jam us up somebody can
have up to two credit cards or debit
cards
get both of them if you if you oh oh my
mom if you throw throw something random
into the cart and then when you check
out it might have
whatever information he gave you should
there should be edit profile i'm in
added profile i'm in payment and there's
no phone number contact number
all right
daniel that's me
uh
favorite save delivery addresses
we have the studio
that's the only one saved [ __ ] now we
know he knows where we are whoa
yikes that's not good no
we're gonna find this son of a [ __ ]
i'll tell you that right [ __ ] now
throwing them off our scent yeah and
definitely get you what's your phone
number
what's your phone number no
[Laughter]
are you on a vpn what are you working
with over there
this is all from when chrysler put his
water on got it right now he [ __ ]
everything up but nothing's been the
same since i don't want to say nothing
leaked it
that's how the pickpocks do you they
bump into you
and they grab your [ __ ] saw one the
other day guy distracts you you look
this way and then they snatch your chain
oh that was in the club
hmm there's no information what do you
got for us nothing i got nothing that's
it all right sounds to me like chase
bank needs to be chasing down some
goddamn leads well all we can do now is
turn it over the cold case and uh who
wants to contact the family that's he
favorite in recent orders
since
he only did it once still fresh then i
know of
two orders 624 to this address
no it's 7 8 2021.
that was me probably yeah chicken bowl
yeah that's me yeah that's kippy right
no chicken bowl chicken bowl chicken
bowl i think it's that was probably us
three there's no i ordered three i never
get chicken from chipotle
i think you're in on this or what if you
have some type of split personality
thing who goes to boston for the weekend
and orders casual dining
and probably kills a couple homeless
guys
could be
man
daniel ryan huh
probably not his real name
i would
assume not he probably
could it be a robo could it be a robo
situation
yeah but then who but yeah like all this
stuff is like you get the money in a
deposit or you buy something to get
shipped somewhere but like this is like
the food is perishable it's not like you
can just like
someone had to eat this food you would
assume i think we should call the cops
and have them do a [ __ ] drive-by at
the house
see if it shakes anybody up where is
that i think we should go and we should
do a drive-by that's
at least askgaryvee for patreon
let's go [ __ ] track these [ __ ]
down i'll borrow someone's gun
we're gonna close relax i'm not gonna
kill him i mean these are probably
dangerous guys no
you take the car kicked a new car
it's north of boston
e
could be the i ties
dynes
whatever
we do have connections up there too with
the boston police department and the fbi
what i'm trying to in case he's
listening
i know the governor
of chipotle
sure
well that's it that's all i got you know
we'll see how this shakes out i'll track
some leads down shake some bushes we're
gonna do a little investigation off air
definitely want to see if we i'm gonna
do a little poking around okay all right
how far away is it from here from new
york um
because right before we leave to get in
the car i'm going to call him and you
know i'm going to say
run
i don't think there's an actual address
to this
four hours and 20 minutes if you want to
take i-84 do you want to take ct-15 wait
what do you mean ct-15 i'm not paying
the tolls all right four hours 17
minutes
what do you mean there's not an address
you
it doesn't show up
it doesn't give you an actual
is he playing stupid is he in on this
what's going on here
this guy's a little touched in the head
i'm saying it doesn't give you an actual
uh
look i'll show you why does it you pin
down let me [ __ ] where did they
deliver the food to i wasn't there or
was i
that's where we start look but i'm
saying it's not falling here's 144.
here's 148. yeah there's no like it's
not falling on anything it's probably at
probably an apartment complex and he
lives on the corner what yeah
he lives in it's that house right there
but that's 140 it says 144. [ __ ]
that's what i'm that's what i'm [ __ ]
saying he comes out to the driveway let
me get up on zillow
he comes out to the driveway he's just
standing there are you chipotle yeah i'm
dan i've got a big head real good
looking like me
what are you guys doing good cop stupid
cop i've seen this a thousand times
nothing comes up on zillow either i
don't think i handcuffed myself
this is you son of a [ __ ] you better
start talking
probably to russians
i've been running my mouth
yeah so that's 144. i don't think 140
that's 144 that's what i showed you i
don't think 146 exists probably a harry
potter type deal yeah probably secret
house
oh well played daniel
you got me dead the rights
change your password on your chipotle
thing i don't even know how to [ __ ]
do that dude
you just opened the account you just got
in there i didn't
i'm gonna need the credit cards moving
forward
so you can go to the blue bell inn
and spend your 38 dollars at emerald
parking don't think i don't see that
[Laughter]
damn they got me these [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right forget about this
post all right i forgot
you guys want anything while i'm here
we should get lunch i'm not gonna lie
yeah i got a hankering for some [ __ ]
sweet corn salsa you know what i mean
picked up a new whip i so i was just in
big black what are you calling it big
boy big boy yeah i was just in a big boy
no it's the hank tank the hang tank's
pretty good it's a big boy he wouldn't
like that
he's angry the wiener wagon
now he's intimidating he's a bulls what
he is it's okay he's a bull you don't
take any any [ __ ]
what are we talking about i saw you
[ __ ] i saw everybody rickshaw cut you
off on [ __ ] 6th avenue i don't have
to drive fast i drive slow with him he
cruises the block
you don't drive everything comes to you
when you're in big boy
it's a good car that's nice so good give
us a rundown i can't afford it i know
why you were throwing some numbers at me
sir and uh
i would have to add enough second hard
feelings everywhere
i gotta say i don't love that you got a
car
because it's in your name and now i got
no leg to stand on when i'm trying to
trash you oh good good good good good
good yeah you're finally a 50 year old
good good good regular
title [ __ ]
come see me
the repo man plans on it
probably daniel ryan
i'll need that one palm address whatever
you got you're gonna be parking that
[ __ ] sideways in your garage so here's
the deal backing in here's the can't
read the plates from the street
i've done that son you want to talk
about trash putting bushes over it
so those nets
[Laughter]
so the drones don't see it
like a real psycho so here's the
swimming pool from
lake they would do that [ __ ]
they would like paint out the [ __ ] uh
planes to look like different planes so
when the russians took pictures over top
it looked like just a regular plane but
really it was the
b1 bomber okay turn your lights out with
those things your nickname b1 bomber
anywho not a bad name for the car but
it's big boy so
my lease was coming up
the lease was in my mother's name even
though i was paying for it every month
all right um
debatable
debatable
full price who knows you know
i mean if you were making the payments
you wouldn't be able to not to be able
to afford this one at the same time just
saying what do you mean what do you mean
well that lease is over
sure yeah
at least is over yeah but it's not like
you went from a kia to a ferrari you
went from a jeep to a jeep the payment
should be relatively aligned with what
the previous payments were they weren't
the previous payments were three hundred
dollars this one your mom paid 500 of it
this one's five uh-huh this one's five
but okay so here's the deal
so
the car was good no question the car was
uh the car was up the the lease was up
on the car
okay
elise was up on the car
um
i could either buy the car
turn the car in get a new lease
obviously we're changing it over into my
name put it in my name so i had a jeep
latitude okay for some reason if i
wanted to buy laddie all right it would
have been
like six hundred and thirty four dollars
buy it and just [ __ ] drive it off the
bridge it would have been crazy it would
have been crazy and if i got a new lease
of that car but a newer version it would
have been like 700. something with the
chips in this one are different than the
chips in that one but it worked we got
doritos in this guy we have fritos in
there and everybody knows i'm a cool
ranged man
spicy nachos or i'm walking right now
so purple one the other day all right
that's spicy nacho no no no no sweet
chili or chili lime or something like
that we were just talking me and t-bone
just gave this run down stop stop to the
deal
on the old garden state parkway to
sunoco right the doritos all right you
know what else was not to shake a stick
at that i haven't had in a long time
pizza combos they're all right oh the
original they're all right that wasn't
the original was it yeah it was pizza
combo wasn't it the original combo we've
done this we're in reruns okay
danny i believe it was a clip show so
listen let's cut the [ __ ] all right
original who are you texting i'm asking
who the original what the original combo
was all right so
that was the situation with the car
okay those are my options so it turns
out that next year they are
redoing the
body or whatever of the grief jank great
jeep whoa hachimachi jeep grand cherokee
limited okay which is what i got
so they're trying to get rid of them i
guess
so stink i was able to get a 2022
cherokee limited as i said
at the dealership okay police
at 10 000 miles a year
it's five bills a month okay
and the insurance wasn't too bad okay
and i asked
most i asked
a couple of my cousins i asked my
brother i asked other people
is that a real because i don't want i
don't want to live outside my means or
whatever yeah why start now
[Laughter]
they all said yeah that's about right
that's about right
for what i got okay that's about right
and there was literally
no other [ __ ] options it was either i
get that one or i get the [ __ ] the
thing there's no [ __ ] cars they don't
got cars no you can dm kia they'll give
me one right off the shop apparently off
the rip
get it off
well i don't want to drive a kia
kevin i'm an american god damn it so you
decided to upgrade from your mom's car
to a car you can't afford so here we are
there we are huh yeah so
this is the phone call i received
actually how much is your insurance i
should be okay with dead right that's
only nine grand a month i should be able
to spin that i don't know what these
humans do i don't know how to [ __ ] be
an adult i don't know what it is guy
could have been telling me anything i
want to know i don't know
however
there was an incident at the dealership
unfortunately now i had to bring patty a
little probably wrote me into some
[ __ ] appearance as well i have to
make
hey you gotta do the company we gotta do
the jeep christmas party okay
it's outside i'll do 550 a month plus me
and kevin will come down every christmas
for three years do the party do a
christening
i had to bring patty with me because
patty had a
sign for you get out of the lease
and turn it over to me or something like
that i can't remember how how it all
fell down guys are like ticks
yeah we are and dude she was so panicked
because like
they're giving her a check that she has
to take to the the bank and drop it off
the bank and yeah she didn't want to she
she's like i'm just just tell them my
brother's like just tell them the
[ __ ] wire jay i don't trust that so
so we [ __ ] go there to pick the car
take mine in cash please we go there two
separate cars what
yeah we took two separate cars to get
there because as soon as she got the
check she was splitting at the door to
get to the bank because it had to be
there a certain day but it really didn't
it was like they give you like a 10-day
you're nuts we get it so we get there
all right
we get there we sit down
i got the insurance got this got that
got that um but going back when we first
went there i imagine you guys walking
into the dealership you're already
fighting and there's some [ __ ] car
sales been sipping his coffee going
about time to make some money
this one had a [ __ ] bullseye on your
head
about to take these poor bastards for
everything they got
keys so terry this is what is known as
generational suckers
i see from the big one
they're all bozos sweet lord you see the
way the parents are fighting that means
the sun's [ __ ]
is that your girlfriend nah it's my mom
bingo
that's all it took was a little charm
you a 46 year old man walking to a
dealership that's clear code all day
baby
never mind
i was going to insinuate your mom had
sex with the dealer like that scene in
forrest gump where he walks i was oh
your mama sure does care about your jeep
grand cherokee boy
but i didn't want to be an [ __ ] but
anyway she might have
so
let's go back to when we to when we were
we were window shopping did he take your
mom out for a test drive too
hey let me let me get a let me get a 55
[ __ ]
go play with the radio
um when we went there initially okay so
we go over there uh-huh this is last
week yeah i picked it up on saturday so
this is going back last week i
i forgot so
we go there try to do some business with
these gentlemen with this gentleman um
gypsies
so we meet behind a kroger and uh
so we pull in i give him three teeth we
put we pull in he checks out my car papa
that's what's gonna be that's what he
wearing on a bernie's in there
not a [ __ ] word and i had just
stepped in gum
i did or no you know what happened
not bragging
this is why you cannot buy used cars you
do not know what's going on oh my god
hope you like boogers
cause you're driving one
literally
shout out to the latitude it's very sad
so i had uh it's happy not to have you
for a minute what are you talking about
the best day was the best days of his
life were in
them i sneezed like two weeks ago when i
was driving and i was chewing gum and it
flew out of my mouth
i think i was on the highway or
something
you are another kind of idiot i said i
was gonna get it later
uh and i forgot about it it was been
real hot
and so it melted into the carpet so i
noticed that when i pulled and i thought
he was just checking it out we were i
wasn't looking to cut a deal you weren't
looking you weren't ready for like the
16 68 point inspection it's first date
no i'm not trimmed up how you
so immediately he goes out and [ __ ]
takes a look at it and i mean it's been
it's [ __ ] that thing was built in
heater city it's [ __ ] cooked in there
yeah throw on the summer ac
to really bring it out of the pores i
know i know it i was in the car
no more than a week ago cooking
didn't give a [ __ ] yeah they i'm sure
they just [ __ ] chemical yeah they
didn't organize it or the [ __ ] it is but
dude and they're so hard up for cars and
it's this whole [ __ ] thing it's wild
the whole thing is [ __ ] wild
so he's like all right
we like to call you know whatever we'll
take the car you know what i mean so
what you want to do is you know two
options are just at the other thing you
ran some numbers on the [ __ ] ladder
on what the new latitude would be you
know yeah i can't really do that [ __ ]
and and but that the car that i have
is the car that i would have regardless
of how much if i was
a billionaire no it's not hey i'm
telling you i [ __ ] you're saying that
i'm telling i under i'm not saying you
don't but you also don't know what you
don't have
i don't know man i i don't think it gets
any better than the [ __ ] jeep grand
cherokee that's what i like i'm not i'm
not sure
i just thought that's an insane
statement i mean i get a helicopter
maybe sure
but i wouldn't drive it but this is also
like the h foley logic in the sense of
like it's what you're maxed out it's
what you could afford you turned a
joyride in a bentley into a personal
attack on me
very true
how you've never been in a bentley have
you
i forget what was the record
what i'm just saying i'm not
be that as it may i'm very happy with
the vehicle i'm
sure you are but this to me this is the
this is this i know you pretty well this
reigns all true to the disney thing of
like disney's [ __ ] stupid because you
can never go
and then you're like i don't need
anything else this is all i need i'm not
saying you don't love it it's great it's
not it's a fantastic vehicle are you
trying to get the fact that i'm crazy
yeah but to be like that's what i would
drive if i was a billionaire it's like
you would for sure not
all right
whatever don't say that in front of big
boy though get pissed off um i don't
know [ __ ] here's this
it almost didn't happen
you don't say you walked in and tried to
get at least and it didn't go smoothly
so we go in there everything looks good
you want this one do you want that one
i'm like listen i love this this is like
actually the car that i would prefer i
just think i'd be even if i was a
billionaire i didn't think i'd be able
to afford it he said you know the prices
are different because you know they're
changing the body they're this step the
other thing whatever
okay
so
they run my credit
all right i instantly get it i think we
have the same credit now by the way i
instantly get [ __ ] hit up by credit
wise that my [ __ ] score dropped just
because they're poking around every time
they every time they do a hard check you
get dinged so now the guy that owns this
place
is friends with still dirtbags is
friends with my mom's like they're
almost like my cousins at any point
during the negotiation did you say come
on it's me there was no negotiation
which i looking back i should have said
can you do any better but i think he was
doing the best he can and doing us a
favor anyway
i don't know should i have said that can
you do any better i thought it was what
it was
no i think it's not casablanca
is there room for negotiation
always [ __ ]
sucker
i wonder why you walked in and paid
[ __ ] sticker price no i paid whatever
he said it would come out to now he paid
sucker price yeah we didn't even pay
sticker price damn hey where do you
charge me well sir it's gonna be 1400 a
month sorry thank you [ __ ]
car's orange too strange
no nothing i want that cut um
[Laughter]
all right he's half in the computer
where are you going nowhere i'm just
sweating i thought you were leaving
so he runs the credit check uh-huh all
right i get shot down
whoa shot down immediately now i'm in
there [ __ ] i i went outside to have a
smoke i'm [ __ ] intense that really
makes your case better
[ __ ] out there [ __ ] i didn't smoke in
that car by the way
out there digging through the ashtray
looking for kills
uh
patty
oh that's giving me anxiety dude
thinking about how she was operating
how many times you were like shut the
[ __ ] up she's like trying to like
entice him
[Music]
like talking about she drops her bra
strap off her shoulder
she's all right she's talking about
friends of my cousins still know debbie
so like yeah like make it more like you
know
to the point that the dude's wife rolled
in okay just you know stopped to see
your husband on a saturday this guy owns
the joint
and um the wife didn't know my mom
hi i'm very you know
i
i hear stories about uh you know him and
you know bread yeah him and fred talk
all the time and the guy's like well i
don't really know fred that well i know
i know his brother or something like
that i'm like patty get the [ __ ] away
from me
so he's sitting there he's running the
thing again okay i'm sitting there with
him all right it's um strike one
okay he went to some
lone people whatever it is
all right
so now he's running it with with with
chrysler you ended up with a gambino
crime family loan
who giveth who gave it to you
he wouldn't got your money on the street
no no institution would give it to you
chrysler gave it to me
bozos didn't they tank in the early
2000s they're giving money away those
[ __ ] idiots that's how you cocas but
here's the capper i'm listening it's a
tense situation this guy's running my
credit score for the [ __ ] second time
okay
my mother disappears
and then reappears
with a paper plate
and a plain uncooked bagel on it
with mustard
squirted on onto the thing
okay
you're following me as you're about to
sign like a
56 000 contract yeah
okay
and i go where the [ __ ] did you get that
and she's like they're over there
like you know like they would have like
a customer service i'm aware
but they didn't
because five minutes later
a guy walks over and goes
did you guys see a bagel
so it was over by the coffee stuff
coffee guy was getting a bagel ran for
some guy he left his bagel he let he was
getting a coffee something happened and
he walked away from it and my mom just
took the [ __ ] bagel and put mustard
on it and put mustard on it no i think
the mustard here was his
who puts mustard on a bagel this whole
thing doesn't make it i don't know but
she was [ __ ] dipping it in mustard
i mean and the guy doesn't say anything
did you guys see a bagel
she's got mustard all over her has
anybody seen mustard in a bagel she's
covered in poppy seeds she ate some
[ __ ] dude's lunch because the guy
without even though what kind of [ __ ]
fugazi ass dealership is this they've
got the owners there on the weekend the
head salesman eating mustard bagels your
mom's stealing it they're giving you a
call what's going on here dude this
place sounds insane
he doesn't even look up from the
computer and goes don't worry about that
and i'm [ __ ] just staring at my
mother this has like this sounds like
you're in a trailer i'm not like one of
those [ __ ] used car that's where i
got to montego
out at my fast uncle eddie's place
i could sell [ __ ] popsicles and white
gloves
so then it comes back i got i got
approved for it this is this is what
it's going to be this that the other
thing [ __ ] okay whatever
so then
i got to get any insurance
right
getting the insurance so she's on the
phone with them
hill patty to get you your insurance yes
to like because because it's it's with
uh usaa
and
since my dad is the service member it's
for service members and their families
so that she's got to do the intro
geico originally did that too that's
what geico stands for what govern
employees insurance company oh
man out to fox business school really
they really slumbed it huh i'm a geico
man are you yeah got that gecko we have
a reasonable rate you and i was about
the same
well yeah it depends yeah the bank makes
if you're leasing the car the bank makes
you
cover cover more yeah i cover more
um
but
i forgot about that little accident that
i had uh two years ago
because they quoted me the new year the
delivery guy no the delivery guy hit me
okay hit me okay
hit me the intersection of foleyville
and reality
i was getting chipotle
um
when they brought that up
because they gave me a quote oh wait a
minute
no accidents and i'm like nah i'm good
and he's like what happened in october
19th at 5 42 p.m and they know like the
street corner yeah
yeah they did they got me 57 at first so
um
dropping the then now picking up the car
was fantastic
but
very sad leaving lady
sure but the excitement of uh big black
yeah
there's a little more so the guy that
was helping me not the owner but the
other guy okay
says you know you go clear you know i'll
pull the thing up whatever it comes
around i'm taking the stuff out of the
car and he goes sir
are you crying
what what is wrong with you people dude
that car got me through [ __ ] so much
man that the little guy i wish i could
take her take her with me
but i couldn't
and i couldn't pass up on be i wish that
i could just keep her as a call just
stop calling it her
i'd get very emotionally attached to the
cars
yeah why
i don't know all right relax just asking
yeah
i was i was tearing up a little bit and
i just said
cutie mustard
what the [ __ ] is wrong with your family
any more bagels left
i just said you know i i had you know i
had this car through a bunch of [ __ ] and
[ __ ] uh i'm sorry i hit a delivery
driver
just [ __ ] chinese food all over the
place
it's like you hit ping inside
got a broad noodle
a flat broad noodle
i just said i was like whatever
and then he would never [ __ ]
give me an english muffin in ketchup
stacks i swear to god
[Laughter]
not skipping a beat he's like you got to
go back and talk to jay i think the
quote went up a little bit
man they saw you coming i guess so i
didn't even think of it to
negotiate what you're crying your mom's
stealing bagels
you can't negotiate yeah yeah you didn't
negotiate
you're
gonna negotiate when you buy something
no
i could have got the lease cheaper you
for sure can't negotiate when they
credit check [ __ ] ding you and they'd
instantaneously deny you
i'll take my business elsewhere
the insurance didn't [ __ ] your will your
mom's rooting through the [ __ ]
cafeteria the employee fridge
you stink eating yogurt what the [ __ ]
she's got a brown paper bag
off a piece of birthday cake
apparently ted
congratulations ted it's his last day
[Laughter]
all right guys
congratulations on the new car it's a
big step into becoming a man at 58 years
old i'm proud of you i also took a huge
deuce and clogged up the toilet too
then i had to wait in there for like
three flushes to the point that people
were not because i needed it to fill up
so i can get it down
yeah
we're gonna do i don't know
police are going to foley huh they're
going to foley
i mean mustard on a bagel yeah which now
that i'm thinking about it i think she
disputed that yesterday when i called
her out on it
yeah of course she wasn't mustard it was
something else
can i answer unless it was cream cheese
icing it wasn't cream cheese was it
yellow yeah that's why that's why i said
i thought it was mustard get her on the
horn and then we got to wrap this up all
right
this was a kooky episode anyway
let's see if we can get her she's
elusive too
yeah she's ducking chrysler
hi buddy hey pinhead let me ask you a
question
what
what was on what was next to the bagel
at the dealership what were you dipping
it in it wasn't mustard
no it was um
spicy jalapeno
spicy jalapeno spicy jalapeno what
okay have you been to massachusetts
recently
no why all right i'll call you later
lobster from name
where
are you at
i'll talk to you later bye
[Laughter]
she going to the pet store
i gotta call her back get to the bottom
of that
knows what that means like she's that
sounds like she's meeting a guy in the
parking lot with a cooler in his trunk
going together she was bragging too i'm
going to get lobsters from maine we're
at the mall
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen those are those
hard feelings and we love you peace